thousands of children from all over
Bosnia and Herzegovina gathered for a
send-off match for their national team
where players competed against young
talents in a showpiece for the
children's charity UNICEF the national
squad is a powerful unifying force in a
country that continues to struggle with
ethnic tensions the World Cup is a
chance for the whole country to get
behind their team that at least is the
hope of star forward verdad Ibisevic
thus it's uh let's unleash on it's given
a lot of people something to be happy
about for once in their lives people
here in Bosnia haven't had so many
reasons to be happy neato filaggrin the
gap yesterday the players have also been
helping to raise funds for the victims
of the flood that devastated parts of
Bosnia last month the scenes of
devastation brought back memories of
bosnia's war which many of the players
experienced as children yah mine female
experienced war 20 years ago now we've
had this new disaster every month but I
think people here know how to fight and
I'm sure that we will survive this
disaster too but my thoughts are with
the people who have been hit by this in
gedanken by buddies a consulate and the
people love their team when Bosnia made
it through to the World Cup Sarajevo was
transformed into one big party
now the fans are hoping for more good
news from Brazil as the next generation
looks on and dreams of a better future